Tewkesbury in gloucestershire Three
Rivers converge here and already parts
of the town are under water
and it's not alone due to heavy rains
dozens of flood warnings are in place in
the southwest of England the Midlands
and Wales we've seen a lot of rain over
the last few days and couple of weeks
which means catchments are saturated and
they're responding now we've got flood
warnings out across the the west of the
country and those flood alerts and flood
warnings are there to help people to
know to prepare and to take action and
the consequences of all that rain are
plain to see
this Believe It or Not isn't a river but
a road already here in Tewkesbury the
rising waters are laughing at the edges
of the Town they've not yet risen far
enough to cause any significant damage
or disruption but the fear is if rain
falls at forecast levels over the next
few days they soon could
not that such fears seem to overly
trouble the locals which is an excuse to
put the Wellies on really it's uh it's
just quite quite normal for us each uh
when the water comes down and water
comes down to seven from from Wales it
you know it's a lot of water coming down
it's got to go somewhere just looks like
a lake you feel as they should take a
boat out really
the question is how much worse it will
get
this is the environment agency's flood
forecast for the river seven at the very
top of its course in Shropshire it's set
to hit record Levels by six o'clock
tomorrow morning
that doesn't mean disaster is inevitable
flood defenses may do their job the rain
may let up but until it does fears will
persist that all this is just the cam
before the storm Matthew Thompson Sky
News Tewkesbury